You're a miracle.
Did you know that?
Today we're going to talk about
animal development and
the miracle of life.
The process that animals go
through to turn, like,
a sperm cell and an egg cell
into a multi-cellular
organism is incredible.
It's not just incredible,
it's unbelievably,
transcendentally magnificent, man. Magnificent!
And dudes... the thing is:
we're all just,
like, tubes!
OFFSCREEN: Dude, no edge.
HANK: I know.
So, animals.
They come in all sorts of shapes
and sizes and smartnesses
and things. And in our infinite
wisdom, humans have come up with
a system of classifying animals
based on how similar they
are to each other.
Today we're going to be talking
about some differences between
animals at the phylum level, here,
which happen at the earliest
stage of development.
That's because a bunch of really
big decisions are made within a
few moments of the sperm
fertilizing the egg,
and how this early embryonic
groundwork is laid makes a big
difference when it comes to what
kind of amazing multicellular
being you're going to end up being.
Or, you know, not so amazing.
Hello, sea sponges!
Animal phyla range from the very
simplest, like sea sponges,
to the more complicated.
Signs of an animal's complexity
include how symmetrical it is,
how many organs it has,
and how specialized its cells are.
A sea sponge, for instance,
is a total freakin' mess
symmetry-wise and doesn't really
have any organs to speak of.
In fact, if you were to blenderize
a live sea sponge and then leave
the sponge smoothie to settle
overnight, you'd wake up the
next morning to find that the
surviving cells had found each
other and were reforming
themselves into a sea sponge again.
Try doing that with any
other animal and-
-actually, NO.
DO NOT TRY DOING THAT
WITH ANY OTHER ANIMAL.
My point is, most animals are more
complicated than sponges, and an
animal's complexity has everything
to do with what happens in the
first couple of hours
of its development.
And here's a neat rule of thumb:
the more complex an animal is,
the more it resembles a tube
with some different stuff
layered around it.
And now's when you're like,
"Uh, Hank... uhh, what?"
Okay, so here's the deal:
A really important clue indicating
that you're dealing with a complex
life form is how many layers of
tissue it makes in its very early
stages of development. Sea sponges
make just one, things like
jellyfish and corals make two,
and all the more complicated
animals make three.
So, the early stages of development
are similar for most animals.
Remember, sperm cells and egg
cells are both gametes,
haploid cells that only carry
one set of chromosomes.
Once the sperm fertilizes the egg,
the two haploid cells fuse their
information together and form
a zygote, one beautiful diploid
cell with two sets of chromosomes
that contain all the instructions
needed to create a
new living thing.
Which is, of course,
totally far out.
Fast forwarding to like an hour
and a half after fertilization:
The zygote has started dividing
and cleaving through mitosis,
resulting in 2, 4, 8, 16 cells
until it creates a solid ball
of 32 cells. This is
actually a morula.
Or more-ah-luh.
At least according to this guy.
LAPTOP: more-ah-luh, or more-u-luh.
And the morula actually looks a lot
like a raspberry, or a mulberry,
which is what it's
named after in Latin.
Mmm, juicy! Morula pie!
Oh god.
They're going to
ban us from schools!
As more cells are created,
the solid wad of cells begins to
secrete a fluid that forms a
space in the center,
resulting in a hollow
sphere of cells called a blastula.
Okay, so pay attention, because
here's where we get down
to the real business.
Most animals that you just sort
of think of off the top
of your head have a mouth, right?
And by the same token,
most of them have an anus.
Yeah, go ahead and get your
giggles out because I'm going
to be saying anus
a lot in this video.
For example, right now!
ANUS.
So most animals have
a mouth and an anus.
Wait for it:
Unless you're a sea sponge!
Sponges don't have a
mouth OR an anus.
And there are also other animals
like your sea anemones,
your jellyfish, your corals,
that have just one hole that
serves as both mouth and anus.
Aren't you glad we're a little
bit more complicated than that!?
It's worth noting that these
animals have radial symmetry.
All their junk kind of radiates
out from a central point that is
their mouthhole-slash-poohole,
and that is a little bit more
sophisticated than having no
symmetry at all, like a sponge,
but just barely.
I mean, their anus and their
mouth are the same thing.
But more complex animals,
with the notable exception
of the echinoderms like starfish
and sand dollars exhibit
bilateral symmetry: We have
two-sided bodies that
look the same on both sides.
Something else we have in common
is we have an anus that is,
get this, in a different
place than our mouth.
This separation is pretty key,
because it means that we as
animals are basically
built around a tube,
a digestive tract, with a mouth at
one end and an anus at the other.
The process of forming this tract
is called gastrulation,
and it's kind of a big deal.
So, when we left our little
blastula, it was still just
hangin' out, a little, round,
hollow ball of cells.
Gastrulation begins when an
indentation starts to form at
a single point on the blastula.
This place on the blastula that
starts to invaginate, or fold in
on itself, is called
the blastopore.
Now for animals whose mouth and
anus are the same thing,
this is where the development
stops, which is why they only
have one hole for
all their business.
But in everything else,
the invagination continues
until the indentation makes its
way all the way through and opens
on the other side, creating what
is essentially a hollow bead
made of cells.
Now we have a gastrula!
Now, two different things can
happen at this point,
depending on what kind of animal
this is going to be. It can either
be an animal whose mouth is the
orifice that's formed by the
blastopore, called a protostome,
or one whose anus is the structure
created by the blastospore,
a deuterostome.
Guess which one you are.
Write it down.
I want to see your guesses.
Chordates, that is to say all
vertebrates and a couple of our
relatives like starfish,
are deuterostomes,
meaning we were once just a
butthole attached to a little
wad of cells.
And that includes you.
And me.
Congratulations!
And hopefully you're getting the
idea here: The formation of the
digestive tract is the first thing
that happens in the development
of an animal, and it happens to
every living thing, whether it's
going to be a tardigrade
or a polar bear or a T Pain.
THE MIRACLE OF LIFE!
Now so far the little hollow bead
of cells is basically two layers
of tissue thick: an outer layer
called the ectoderm, and an inner
layer called the endoderm.
These are called your germ layers.
For those organisms that stop
developing at this point,
with that classy mouth-anus combo,
they only get two germ layers.
They're called diploblastic,
and they were born that way,
it's totally OK.
But for us more complex animals,
whose mouths are separate
from our anuses-
Yes!
we develop a third layer of tissue,
making us triploblasts.
Here, the ectoderm is going to end
up being the animal's skin, nerves,
spinal cord and most of its brain,
while the endoderm ends up forming
the digestive tract: the esophagus
and stomach and colon and stuff.
And in addition, some of the cells
start breaking off between the
endoderm and the ectoderm and
form another layer called
the mesoderm.
These will eventually end up as
the muscles, circulatory system,
reproductive systems, and
in the case of vertebrates,
most of the bones.
So what's our embryo looking
like now? Awesome. From here,
this little guy is going to go on
to fulfill his destiny as a
ladybug or walrus or whatever.
And now this seems to me like a
great time take a look at a
completely disproven theory that
biologists hold in the highest
contempt, but which is actually a
kind of useful way to think about
the way an animal embryo develops
into fully-formed animal.
Plus, it makes for a great
BIOLO-GRAPHY!
Back in the mid-1800's a German
zoologist named Ernst Haeckel
tried to prove what we now refer
to as Recapitulation Theory.
Basically, and this is not basic
at all, recapitulation theory
states that "ontogeny
recapitulates phylogeny."
Eh?
In other words, ontogeny,
or the growth and development
of an embryo, recapitulates,
or sums up, phylogeny,
which is the evolutionary
history of a species.
So this means, for instance,
that a human embryo over the
course of its development,
will go through all the
hundreds of millions of years
worth of evolutionary steps
that it took for a single-celled
organisms to evolve into a
fully-tricked-out person.
Haeckel was a contemporary
of Darwin, and On the
Origin of Species made a giant
impression on him, especially
a section of it that notes how
cool it is that all vertebrate
embryos look pretty similar
to one another, regardless of
whether they're a mammal
or a bird or a reptile.
Darwin, however, cautioned that
this probably wasn't a very good
way of reconstructing the
history of evolution, he just
thought it meant that the
embryological similarities
were evidence of common
ancestry between species.
Well, Haeckel was kind of a spaz,
and he definitely heard the first
part of Darwin's idea,
but not the rest.
So Haeckel jumped on this idea
and very quickly wrote a couple
books about how the development
of an embryo mirrors the
evolutionary development
of adults of a species.
Which is exactly what Darwin
said was not happening.
Anyway, Haekel did spend a lot
of time looking at embryos
and observed that the slits
in the neck of the human embryo
resembled gill slits of fish,
which he took to mean that we
must have at one point
had a fish-like ancestor.
He drew tons of figures of
different animal embryos in
different stages of
development to prove his theory,
and his illustrations of embryos
started to make their way
into textbooks all over the world.
Haeckel is exactly the sort of
person who really ticks other
scientists off because real
science-loving scientists
like to sit and think about
stuff and find out all the
problems with an idea before
they start publishing books
about it.
And here Haeckel was,
firing off volume after volume,
and before long all the "data"
he had "collected" convinced a
bunch of other people,
including Darwin actually,
that he was onto something.
But in the end it turned out that
Haeckel was kind of fiddling with
his drawings of embryos to make
the data fit his
Recapitulation Theory,
instead of, you know,
making the theory
to fit the data.
But by that time,
everybody already
knew about the theory,
and if there's anything harder
than teaching people something,
it's unteaching them something.
So, here we are, almost 150 years
later, and we're still talking
about the Recapitulation Theory.
But that might have less to do
with the stubbornness of
a bad idea than it does with the
fact that it actually makes a kind
of sense when you don't
take it literally.
At some point in our embryonic
development, humans actually do
have gills slits like a fish,
and tails like a dog or a pig
or a jaguar, and webbed fingers
and toes like a frog.
So while it's not true that
every zygote re-enacts all
of animal evolution,
the way that an animal
develops does reminds us
that we are, in fact,
related to other Chordates.
And we all start off
as just a tube.
A mouth at one end,
an anus on the other.
Which is pretty freakin' amazing.
Thank you for watching this
episode of Crash Course Biology.
If you're confused about any of
the anus-anus that we covered
today you can go back
and watch that now.
If you have any questions for us,
you can leave them down in the
comments below or
on Facebook or Twitter.
Thank you for watching,
and we'll see you next time.